A turn of the crank, a spin of the wheel
Fear, dread, excitement. What is it you feel?
The cycle resets, we live once more
To repeat the mistakes we’ve made before.
So again, we join our Yellow Friend.
Remember, my dears, death is never the end.
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory, the best
theory show online provided you log in first.
Too bad for you, I guess. For
everyone who does remember
their password today we're diving back
into the twisted world of Don't Hug Me,
I'm Scared. In case you need a quick refresher,
Don't Hug Me, I'm Scared or DHMIS started as
a classic YouTube horror series that
mixed Tickle Me Elmo with Dead Space.
It was children's edutainment with a heavy dose
of existential dread. But then earlier this year,
DHMIS did the impossible. It got itself a
full blown, real life TV show on the British
Channel 4. And whoa boy, is this thing full of
cryptic secrets and hidden mysteries. For one,
this guy right here, the Yellow Guy,
he's probably a dead kid. Because,
of course he's a dead kid. This is a theory
channel after all, we've got our standards.
In this case. We theorize that Yellow Guy is the
puppet representation of a child named David,
a child who was tragically
killed by his mother, Lesley,
during a car accident. The doll house and
puppet world of DHMIS that we now see is
just Lesley trying to come to grips with
this traumatic event from her past and move
on. But that's hardly been the only theory
that's popped up around this new series.
One major unsolved mystery revolves around these:
Strange symbols that appear in various locations
all throughout the six episode run. I actually
first noticed these back during the Fly teaser
in spring of 2022, as one of the symbols
appeared on a sticky note in the fridge.
At the time, we had nothing to go off of
and our resident chemistry expert Steph
was able to confirm that it wasn't some
sort of chemical structure. So we filed it
away as a weird little detail that might pop up
again, and pop up again it did loyal theorists.
These symbols are everywhere on the
show, on computers, on refrigerators,
on blackboards, and most notably of
all, on the cover of the mysterious
book that Lesley gives Yellow Guy
in the final episode of the season.
You wanted this... didn't you?
And while at first these little drawings
might seem just like random shapes used to
decorate the scene, in reality, they're symbols
with a deeper meaning that can absolutely be
solved. And that's important because these
characters are clearly stuck in a cycle,
and decoding the book might be their
only hope in breaking that cycle.
Don't forget to change your batteries
loyal theorists, because it's theory
time, it’s theory time. You'll see.
Now, while I'd love to sit here in the
recording closet and tell you that today's episode
is going to be me solving the symbol mystery.
I can't do that, because someone
else beat me to the punch. You see,
as I was doing research for this episode, I
stumbled across a series of videos produced
by the Channel RemGames here on YouTube,
a series of videos where he claimed to do
exactly what I was trying to do, solve the
coded message on the front of the book.
And after watching the videos, you know
what? I think he pretty much nailed it.
Me and the rest of Team Theorist loved the
way that he solved the mystery. So instead
of just rehashing it all ourselves,
only to come to the same conclusions,
we decided to invite him over today to
represent his research in the episode. Hey Rem.
Hey, I'm Remy. Yes, like the rat. I'm a YouTube
gamer and theorist who tolerates FNAF and
uses glitchy text in my video titles.
Welcome to the family, sir. Something
tells me you're going to fit right in.
I also like the internet creepy pasta stuff,
which is how I got involved with the whole Don't
Hug Me mystery. You see, while I was watching,
I noticed a few of the symbols showing up over
and over again. Obviously, the biggest and most
important one is going to be on the cover
of the book that Lesley gives to Yellow Guy.
But you'll notice that inside that big symbol
are a bunch of smaller ones, the ones that we see
repeated in other parts of the world. For example,
this symbol here on the top right can be seen on
the spine of the yellow book in the show's intro.
Or the symbol here, which appears in both
the show's trailer, as well as
this spatial distribution that
Yellow Guy drafts up in the final episode.
Clearly they mean something. They're put in
those places with intent. But how do you start
to figure out what they could possibly mean?
Well, you look for instances where a symbol
is directly related to something someone says,
and that's exactly what we get in episode four.
Try my name. Oh yeah. OK.
That inverted P is Duck's name.
This is further supported by the
fact that during Duck’s funeral in episode
two, we see that same symbol on his plane.
Again, the symbol and Duck are connected.
Exactly. But you know where else he shows
up? Here on this title card from episode three
Family. What do you see? But do you see what else is there?
It's another one of these symbols. The one
with a bunch of circles and curved lines.
So knowing that the one symbol represents Duck,
what have we just seen happen to him in the
story? Well, Red Guy has joined him for dinner
back at the house. That curvy symbol represents
Red Guy. That's why it's their two names on this
title card and why Yellow Guy isn't mentioned.
And again, that's not the only time that we see
this symbol making sense as Red Guy's name. We
see the symbol appear again in the trash of
Red Guy's office during episode one Jobs.
Clearly, this is him throwing away paperwork
that's been addressed to him. There's also
the sticky note that's on the fridge that
I mentioned earlier, which would make sense
if he's marking something on the fridge as
his. So lastly, we need Yellow Guy's name.
And while we don't have as 1
to 1 evidence to show this,
we can figure it out by process of
elimination. When the show shows a
wide shot of Lesley's dollhouse in episode six,
we can see three symbols written on the walls.
The first is Duck's name. We know that
for sure. The second is Red Guy's name,
which we feel highly confident in,
which means that the last symbol here;
this little robot face with a pointy tail by
process of elimination, that must be Yellow Guy.
Which now brings us back to the mystery book.
Within that one huge symbol on the cover,
you can see all three characters are represented.
But why? What are the creators trying to say
with this new language and what are these
other symbols connected to our main three?
Well, if we look at the way
that the cover is constructed,
it can actually tell us a lot. This is going
to be a massive oversimplification of some
complicated linguistics, but there are a lot
of different ways to make a written language.
For example, English and other romantic
languages are made up from alphabets.
They have letters that you can put
together to form syllables or words,
and then you can use those to
make up more complicated ideas.
But that's not the only way to make a written
language. Another major way is by using logograms,
where different symbols represent individual
words. Kanji in Japanese and ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphics: Those are examples of logographic
writing systems. But if you take it one step
further than logograms, you get ideograms, which
are symbols meant to represent entire ideas.
So stuff like numbers or the
symbols that we use in math,
those are ideograms. The number “1”
represents the entire concept of one,
just like the + symbol represents
the entire concept of addition.
Languages made up from ideograms are able to tell
very complex stories with relatively few symbols.
If you want an example, we can look at UNLWS or
the Unker Non-Linear Writing System. Using this,
we can break this big squiggly line into
smaller squiggly lines, each with their own
individual meaning like “me” or “eats”. But put
together this symbol means “I eat a large fish”.
So given how the individual symbols on the cover
of Lesley's book all flow into one another,
it would make sense, then, that the DHMIS
language works in a similar way to UNLWS.
Yup, the individual symbols each convey an idea that can be put together to
make a much longer and more complicated
story. This would also explain why it
took Red Guy so many keystrokes to type out
Yellow Guy's name in the computer episode.
Maybe it's my name? Try my name.
Remember the hyphen.
He has to combine a bunch of symbols
to create the idea of Yellow Guy.
Also, it's, you know, just a funny joke.
Yeah, that too, I suppose. Sometimes some
things are in there just to be funny.
No, never. We take everything way too
seriously here. There is no such thing
as a joke or an Easter egg in this house.
No, sir. Just a bunch of sloppy lore.
Don't you mean…
LORE
Not bad. (he tried his best)
Why, thank you.
But what's it all mean? Sure. We've decoded the
three major symbols. We know how the writing
system works. But what's it all trying to say?
Honestly, I'm not sure. I think it relates to
those windows in Lesley's room. I'm actually
glad you brought those up, because they're
one thing that you kind of glossed over in your
videos and something that I haven't seen anyone
else fully address. Just to fill everyone in.
When Yellow Guy first enters Lesley's room,
he walks past a series of three windows, each
with an item from one of the episodes on display.
There's a square window with the
Chuddle Dollops from episode three:
Family. A diamond window with the shovel
from episode two: Death. And a circular
window with the batteries from episode
six: Electricity. But notice the lining
on those windows. They're colored: Green,
Red and Yellow, which obviously is going
to line up with the characters in the
series Duck, Red Guy and Yellow Guy.
But the items don't really seem to line up
with the colors they're assigned to. I mean,
sure, the batteries in the yellow window
make sense because in that final episode,
Yellow Guy changes his batteries and
suddenly becomes smart. But Duck can't
open the bag of Chuddle Dollops in episode three.
Now, let's dive into these Chuddie D's. Open up! Open up! I can't.
In the end, it's Red Guy
who manages to open the bag.
I think things might go a little differently this time. I guess we could share - I want both!
I know. And the same thing happens with the
shovel. Despite being in the red window,
Red Guy is the only one to never interact
with the shovel at all in episode two.
Yellow Guy uses it to dig up Duck, and Duck
ultimately uses it to kill his doppelganger.
Actually no. Four doesn't work. There's three of us.
So why would these items be associated
with characters who fail to use them on
the show? Well, I suspect it's a
hint to the greater story that's
happening here. The same story
that's being told by the book.
You see, Don't Hug Me, I'm Scared is
a story all about characters stuck in
a loop. Not only does Lesley outright
say this at the end of episode five.
No matter how much the wheels turn. The journey always ends up back at home.
Other characters openly acknowledge
how repetitive their lives are.
All we do is sit around and then some guy comes and tells us about banks or vegetables.
The cycle really seems to be getting to Red Guy.
We live in an actual nightmare!
And of course, there's the picture
of Yellow Guy walking up the stairs
as he's walking up the stairs. This is
clearly not the first time he's done this,
despite having no explicit memory
or knowledge of it in the past.
So if we're in a cycle that repeats over and
over, maybe there are parts of the story that
play out differently in different repetitions of
that cycle. During this iteration of the loop,
Yellow Guy ended up with the
batteries while Duck used the
shovel to kill his doppelganger and
Red Guy opened the Chuddle Dollops.
But clearly things aren't quite right.
Things didn't turn out for the best.
And that's because things didn't align with
what Lesley has up here in a room. Red Guy
didn't end up using the shovel, and Duck
doesn't open the Chuddle Dollops himself.
That would actually make sense. We know for a fact
that things can change during each loop. First of
all, we see recurring characters and props from
the YouTube series appearing here on the TV show,
things like the clock teacher, the notepad,
the computer teacher, and even the food guy.
They're all here but are used in very different
ways. There's also repeated references to Clay
Hill, the town that was supposed to be the focus
of DHMIS's original TV pilot. It's here, crossed
out on the blackboard of the Big Boys Room. As
well as here during the transportation episode.
And what about just just down here? I'm sorry that place doesn't exist anymore.
It shows that the cycle has some level
of awareness of the past, but with small
changes in each run.
Inside joke, or lore?
And then here, just take a look at this house
from the beginning of episode five, compared
to this house from the beginning of Episode six.
Notice anything different? For the House in the
episode six intro: there are additional bricks
on the corners, all the curtains and windows
are different colors and there are fewer trees
around the house when compared with episode five.
This would make sense because this is a different
house in a different loop. Remember, Lesley has
to reset everything at the end of episode five.
And this, my friends, is what I suspect the book
is for. It's telling Yellow Guy the correct series
of events that he and his friends need to do,
explaining what Duck needs to do with the Chuddle
Dollops, what Red Guy needs to do with the shovel,
what Yellow Guy needs to do with the
batteries. It's telling Yellow Guy and
us the story that needs to happen in
order for everything to move forward.
We even get hints of it on the cover,
thanks to the pictures embossed in the
leather. There's a lot of stuff on
here that we can recognize from the
first six episodes. Duck’s decapitated head,
Yellow Guy's dismembered hand, the shovel,
the batteries, the coin. But a lot of it just
doesn't quite fit right. Notice the worms.
Sorry. Notice the “Eagles” around the coin and
battery. That character had nothing to do with
either of those stories. There's also this
weird, decapitated Yellow Guy head on here,
something that, again, we didn't
see in the first six episodes.
Why are all of these markings on the book if they
never happened? Well, maybe it's because they're
supposed to happen. This book is literally
a script for the right series of events to
help break the loop, to end the suffering,
the torment, so everyone can just move on.
Speaking of scripts, you know one thing that
never quite sat right with me throughout these
first six episodes? Grolton and Hovris.
At random points throughout the episodes,
the show just takes a break from the
action so the characters can sit down
and watch clips from this in-universe
Wallace and Gromit spin off. It is weird,
it is random, and the sequences can
last for a surprisingly long time.
I just realized. Brother's visit isn't until next month. Oh well.
Grolton is the dog. No, Grolton is the man and Hovris is the dog, I reckon.
But you know that when a creator chooses to
include something so prominently in
their series, you gotta ask yourself,
why? So I did. Have you noticed who worked
on these episodes? Lesley. In episode three,
we can actually see that she's credited
as a script editor for Grolton and Hovris.
And that's interesting because it means that
in DHMIS, Lesley holds a position of creative
power. So if she's a script editor and also
happens to be handing Yellow Guy a book that
explains everything, it's likely the book is
a script for the correct sequence of events.
The only question left is why? What's it
all for? Well, it might be due to forces
beyond their control. You see, during one of
my rewatches, I noticed this offhand joke in
episode two, as Lamp explains what
he thinks happens in the afterlife.
Well, something tells me that when we die, we go into the center of the earth. And we must re-live our lives,
but as a performance for a new super race known as "the council." And every time you get it right you get a pound.
When I first watched the show, that always struck
me as a bit weird. An off the wall joke that was
just so strange that it didn't make any sense. But
then I realized that this is how episode one ends.
Oh yes, I almost forgot! You've earned this.
Duck is given the DHMIS equivalent of a £1 coin
while everyone else is left penniless. Now,
this could be Duck's digital currency based
around respect, but if we take what the lamp
said at face value, this must mean that they
weren't being paid by the council for their
parts in reenacting this part of their lives.
We've theorized in the past that Red Guy has
a creative soul, but in his Jobs episode
he winds up as a manager of the factory.
Knowing what we know about him, he would
never be a manager at a factory like that.
He didn't do it right. Same thing with Yellow
Guy. As the episode goes, Yellow Guy grows old
in the factory and ultimately retires to be with
his family. But if Yellow Guy is really David,
then he wouldn't have lived nearly as long
as we see him live during the storyline.
It appears that whatever happened in
this episode with Duck was a part of
the correct order of events needed for
the series to progress, which also means
the council are the people deciding it
all. But then who or what is the council?
Well, at first I thought that maybe the council
represented the cast and crew of the series,
the creatives working to make the show a
reality. After all, the show breaks the fourth
wall constantly with performers, producers
and directors visible to us as the audience.
Like here, during episode four where we can
see several puppeteers, Red Guy’s actor,
even co-creator Becky Sloan during the
episode itself. Or here in episode six,
where Yellow Guy sees two of the puppeteers
piloting the teachers in the Big Boy room.
But then I remember that there's a
level in the house above Lesley's room,
accessible via a stairwell hidden in the back
corner. And so if Lesley is a creator of sorts,
then what's above creators in a creative
industry? Well, that's the people with
the money: producers who won't proceed with
scripts and fund them until you get it right.
Heck, you could even argue that
there may even be a level above
them: the audience who seem to be more
than willing to watch the same stories
over and over and over again
with just slight variations,
but also an audience who immediately blows up and
gets angry when something is just slightly off.
It's funny, the Don't Hug Me, I'm Scared
YouTube series spent so much of its hidden
mystery talking about creatives and how money
corrupted what should be a pure form of art with
kids entertainment. I was actually surprised
that the TV show seemed to veer so far away
from that sort of meta commentary, since it
seemed so important to the creators in that
original series. I suppose we just needed
to look a little bit harder, didn't we?
Is this. Is this when we get to say the thing?
Yep. This is when we say the thing.
But hey, that's just a theory!
A FILM THEORY aaaaaaaaaand CUT!
And a huge, huge thank you to RemGames for
joining us on this episode and sharing his
incredible research with us. Please do me
a favor. Go over to his channel right now.
It's linked on screen. And watch his six part
series covering DHMIS. He goes into so much
more detail about stuff we didn't have the
chance to cover today. Let me tell you, he
is digging even further into the mysteries of the
series, and other series. So go give them a watch
and then do me a favor. Comment on his latest
video something funny. Make sure your comment
includes the words “Fluffer Nutter” because I
just think that's a really funny troll word.
Thank you so much for having me on. It's been
an honor being here. I'd like to thank my dog,
my fish, my lobster, my dodo bird and
Toucan Sam. Over on my channel I have a
bunch of videos that are theory based, analysis
based, and whatever else your heart desires,
including a few things that any of you who
are theorists might want to check out. And
I like to interact with all of you, so don't be
shy to communicate. Again, thank you so much to
the entire team behind the Film Theory videos.
This has been super fun and absolutely amazing.
And lastly, as we wrap things up, this is one
final reminder of our Film Theory holiday merch,
the awesome Film Theory Academy hoodie
to keep you nice and cozy this winter,
the matching Screen Fiend T-shirt, this
mysterious little analog horror VHS plushie
that can terrify you when you snuggle up. It
also may have secrets of its own to unlock.
Just make sure you get your orders
in either today or tomorrow to ensure
delivery before Christmas. Again,
all of that is down on the merch
shelf or in the description. And
as always, I'll see you next week.